[Music]
hey you guys and thanks for tuning in to
ET live I'm Katie Krauss and Rafi and
Ross Lynch are here but it's for your
guys's new music project the driver era
your new song is called preacher man
it's so good and I was telling you this
earlier that when I first heard it I had
no idea it was you guys so is that the
goal yeah there was definitely some sort
of animosity involved that we liked we
liked the idea of that yeah okay you
want to like depart from what you did
with our five what you've done in the
past no I just want to try something
different yeah I don't never think we
think of it as like a departure yeah it
was just a natural progression as to
what we wanted to do yeah I mean it's
always it's always that way you know
with anything it's just like I want to
do this now yeah that's all I get is
we're gonna play a clip of the music
video and a few guys are tuning in and
make sure you send your questions we're
gonna get them right here on the iPad
we're gonna ask them well let's play the
clip of the video do we need to watch it
we get to watch it
it's a steamy video
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm ashamed
[Applause]
but don't use another kit
[Music]
I mean wasn't I supposed to yeah of
course I had a great time on that shoot
- you wouldn't make me not with a girl
you're even about that it was just about
like being with your friends having a
night to just like have fun in music
videos are the most stress-free
environment Oh as far as like shooting
content yeah she really just like having
a good time shooting music obviously
this one was a little bit more like like
I guess like crazy like there was a lot
going on well how did the concept come
about for this video are you guys
involved in that at all yeah that was
that was all is I just always comes from
the song it's always about you know what
you want the visuals to really enhance
the song our joy and joy and for a
preacher man it has this especially
lyrically has this sort of like like
lost and you keep making such a choices
sexual tension thing going on hmm
so um that's the visual that I thought
was appropriate okay any of the Jesus
Saves sign in the background it goes
together really yeah yeah I mean you're
bound to get some sort of backlash when
you do anything like that but yeah it's
like kind of not liking that it was like
a bubble bath tub Wow Roswell's in the
bathtub like having a romantic time it's
a sensitive time yes for anything
sure absolutely the climate right now is
just people are gonna take offense to a
lot of things um did you guys have a say
in the casting process no but oh wait no
I did actually you did I did you didn't
you didn't whoa like yeah you know be
sensual with no yeah so uh so yeah I
think if I remember correctly oh did you
shoot that that was in January okay yeah
so it was a good time talk about the
lyrics cuz you mentioned I mean they're
a little bit sensual they're different
you talk about stumbling home at 6:00
a.m. playing a heart like a violin who
inspired the song who inspire
yeah like a specific person is there a
specific just-just-just instances of
just like the lyric says is like I'm
sure everyone's had that moment where
you're like coming home at 6 a.m. and
you wanna feel like a little bit lost
because you you know after you come
moments exam after you've been out
longer than like 3 am sure you're like
what am I doing here why like so so yeah
you just feel a little bit lost and
maybe there's a girl involved as I'm
sure that many times there have been but
yeah you miss a do you feel like the
Hollywood lifestyle has ever interfered
in your personal life in a negative way
because you get some I think really I
think you can interfere with creativity
for sure I think a lot of people get
caught up in this Hollywood kind of like
you know you're awake for the whole
night and you're sleeping in the day and
you're there's so many people that leave
no way you know you're not necessarily
taking care of your body in the right
ways you should and so you're also not
being productive and creative during the
day and I think a lot of a lot of young
people get caught up in that mm-hmm for
sure and then personally you just
there's like I don't we've never really
been in this situation but you see a lot
of toxic relationships because of that
lifestyle sure that's really interesting
to observe how do you guys or do you
have ever lean on each other to stay you
know I'm the good and righteous path oh
my gosh yeah we're pretty we focus yeah
yeah yeah like we definitely have our
fun don't get me wrong
we love to like go dancing but uh I
think a freaking yeah I think we enjoy
our nights out for sure but I think we
enjoy our time in the studio a little
bit more so I think that always wins
yeah it's like hey should we you know be
productive this week or should we be
having fun usually what we choose to
work okay he's been gone for some time
so we're only a week bro just tell me
all the way here he was like it's kind
of weird thing I don't know if I just
said I mean what we were kind of
catching up on a lot on the drive I was
driving we were like no we just spend so
much time together so now that I'm up in
Canada like filming and it's only been a
week but it feels like a month yeah so
it's just kind of like we're gonna get
to that yeah we'll get to that we'll get
some greenest
and that is also why they've dyed their
hair different colors or each other's
old colors we're gonna take a few fan
questions though cool from YouTube
typical live says what can we expect for
the live shows from the driver era are
there gonna be live show so that's
something that's something that's I feel
always always been one of our biggest
strengths in music it's just how we like
yeah ourselves live we've been doing it
for 10 years so we're definitely gonna
get back on the road at some point right
now we're sort of in the code and the
stages of like collecting a lot of music
and trying to beat out songs you know
what I mean trying to get the best song
so we can create whatever but that's
still very much up in the air we have a
lot of cool ideas for this show if
anything it'll probably be just like
weekend festivals oh wow for the rest of
the year because he's filming so we
can't actually tour or open
yeah cuz I was the original plan prior
to that happening it was like you know
summer the whole thing but now it'll be
probably next year before we actually do
any kind of real full extensive tour
it's a good point though cuz where do
you find the time to actually make more
music I assume there's more songs coming
you said maybe an album what's the plan
for that that that is the plan just make
because we can't tour is just gonna be
kind of gather songs release songs and
do that for until which is actually kind
of nice because often times too many
times we've been rushed into situations
that were not always like particularly
the I mean we're definitely proud of a
like a lot of the work that we've done
well it's super nice to like get some
time to really like construct what you
want to do and what you want to say then
like presented to the world yeah
so that's kind of what this opportunity
presents which is kind of nice
what do you want to say with this
project moving forward like what the
messaging well we have a lot of thoughts
I guess it's not really worth about what
this might yeah I don't know I'm just
happy I guess someone said that and said
actually yesterday they were like are
you always happy and I was like only cuz
I like
he's always happy every time I've
interviewed you you know happy yeah the
messaging yeah well I mean in the
creation of the driver era a lot of
people were asking us that what do you
want to say like what do you represent
mm-hmm and I don't think it needs to be
that like specific rocky and I have a
lot of ideas and we have a lot of
thoughts when we have a lot of things we
want to share mm-hmm I think as long as
we stay true to ourselves and be honest
then then it's all good you know what I
mean amen
well the sound be similar to what
preacher man sounds like is that kind of
what you guys are going for sonically
there's there's a lot of variety yeah in
the sound there's a lot of eclectic
influences there's there's actually a
there's like an email chain going around
that we sent to like a like a bunch of
our friends a bunch of label people kind
of just anybody that just kind of
curious on their opinion it was like
five songs and every single song on this
email chain was entirely different to
preacher man and the rest of the songs
to be honest so like the sound is there
could be another song that kind of has a
very alternative soul rock feel that
preach man does but as of now that
doesn't even exist the next song it will
probably probably be released is like I
keep calling it it's a beach trap that's
like you saying yes okay sweet and I
don't you know what that's next song to
be released but that's probably the next
song we'll send a mixing timeline for
that we want to give preacher man a
really good chance yeah and it is
already on Spotify it's doing yes
honestly it's had the best reaction of
anything we've released ever so so far
that's amazing oh I'm responsible for
like it's great alternative radio
stations have already added it which is
mind-blowing for us which is cool it's
so you never what we never played on
alternative before like we put only put
on top 40 yeah maybe honey I see yeah do
you prefer this um it's just a system
strategy it's just different that's all
the same you know all you really want
to accomplish is a lot of people here in
the music yeah you know in liking the
music are people surprised when they
hear the song and they realize who it is
like I was surprised um other people
been it's I feel like most the most the
reactions that we've seen it become from
like fans that have been with us for 10
years yeah so and they knew it was us
because we presented it too right you
were the first person actually that I
think I've heard say that you didn't
know was us yeah I didn't know so far
but you know we've been cooped up like
Jessica on facebook says rocky do
blondes have more fun
mmm I think so I've ever since you know
this went down I've been having so much
fun so yeah Isabella says is our five
officially over or just taking a break I
don't think there really is such a thing
is like over or like the end like we're
still alive you know I mean so I thank
you
huh that's ambiguous well I'm just
saying like like Never Say Never there's
always a possibility for anything yeah
anything can happen you know what I mean
what does the family think of this new
project and they saw everybody do it
are they oh yeah yeah we've we like we
send them all the songs all the time and
just to get feedback and stuff in there
they love it on YouTube farheen says how
it oh I was gonna ask you this how is
filming for Sabrina belly it's going
really well
yeah yeah yeah I'm actually like I was a
little like there were certain
reservations that I had to say yes to
this project
obviously because there was a lot of
music going on there's preacher man it's
very exciting a lot of people reacted to
it
but I really believed in this project I
just had a good feeling about it and I'm
happy to say that so far my expectations
have been exceeded really why just the
aesthetic of everything and the actors
that were cast in that and Roberto the
showrunner is like everyone's all that
all the visions are coming together and
they're effective because sometimes
you'll you'll be pitched a certain thing
and they won't come to fruition and
you're like this was not like when I
signed up for
yeah and you know sometimes like in like
a network you get in the way thankfully
we're working with Warner Brothers and
Netflix huge so it's yeah you you have a
certain freedom with that but yeah the
cast is super great and I'm I'm really
having a good time bonding with him for
the first week did you have a chemistry
read with Kiernan ahead of time I
actually only did chemistry reads oh
really yeah yeah so what was that like
what was the whole audition process like
it's pretty quick I auditioned I
literally went in for a chemistry read
that's my first read with Kiernan they
were like apparently they had been
looking for this Harvey character for a
long time I didn't audition because I
was looking for TV and then they were
like oh cool yeah we like her awesome I
was like okay cool
went in again for a like Warner Brothers
live test which means there's no cameras
it's just like a bunch of executives in
a room and you like walk in you do the
season then you leave I mean it's a
really interesting process really I've
never done something like that before
and then I got a call the next day and
said your flights tonight so really
really fast how do you make your
decision then pretty quickly yeah
obviously
it felt if I if I like it was the right
thing they did yeah had you met Kiernan
before this no no so there's your first
time yeah I kind of liked it that way
yeah gives me a chance to like fall in
love with her character you know sure
had you watched the Melissa Joan Hart
series at all how now have you mmm
still have it only who wants it no you
want to bring your show is really
different is it darker I feel like it's
gonna be a little bit darker very much
though and what about the Riverdale
crossover we saw a group picture hmm
it's you hanging out with them okay that
wasn't for the crossover episode though
no I there's no talks over crossover
right now I don't I don't know if
they're ever would be one because the
show we're on different networks right
there's different like aspects of the
shows that wouldn't necessarily work
together we'll see I'm on this like I
said it before anything's possible but
I'm had a great time at the wrap party I
will say that you went out with all that
oh yeah it was good yeah yeah we had
good fun I wish you would have been
there man you know
out working in the studio or something
probably your beretta Ferrari
oh yeah so you didn't watch the original
but you never had the comics either I've
read Roberto's comics which are the new
lists so it's a different version of the
first yeah like they remade the comics
in 2014 which I like much more just kind
of like they're like really cool if you
just google it you'll see them you can
tell the difference between the old ones
and the new ones and then our shows
based off like the new one okay
wardrobe-wise what can you tell us Wow
like are we and what is Kiran wearing
what are you wearing I'm curious I don't
I don't know how much how like far I can
talk about it so I don't want to like go
like okay to far okay everything's
classic guitar classic that's that's
what I'm gonna say yeah can you
elaborate on the darker you said it's
gonna be darker than the original can
you elaborate on that just a little bit
well the original was a sick home and
this is gonna be more of a drama yeah
it's it's hour-long episodes okay
enough likes here okay what about the
romance part of it there's definitely my
plate Sabrina's boyfriend Harvey
okay so there's definitely a romance
aspect to it and that's established
right away yeah let's find out no
because Lily we haven't even finished
filming the first episode okay so you've
just done the table read and you've done
your filmography now a shot two scenes
that's it that's it yeah I thought they
were great we're gonna take a few more
of these thank you yeah Cheers don't
like the hot seat for a minute Shannon
on Facebook says why did you decide to
name the project the driver era where
did the inspiration for the name come
from hmm we actually had another name
but yeah that'll never probably be known
unless someone someone else that knows
that you know lets it lose but it was
Ross and I were basically just driving
we like to get my car and kind of
brainstorm sometimes and we're just
talking about
life in the future and the past and just
kind of where we're at in our individual
lives and then that name kind of just
came up I think that's basically I like
what you said though it was like you
said it recently it was like the perfect
combination of like passive yeah yeah
it's just it kind of just puts you
perfectly in the present right now okay
Marissa says are you guys single or
dating anyone it's kind of hard to date
people yeah
I'm not actually found someone recently
that I really like wanted to date when
you're busy too so it's you are gonna
date someone you want to make sure that
it's the right person oh yeah is for me
it's kind of funny cuz once once Ross
left for Vancouver all of a sudden I was
like oh I'm like hanging I was just kind
of like this girl like sure these girls
and I was like this is kind of weird
like I normally didn't do this I think
it's because Ross is almost like my
other half like here yeah if I'm going
to get a cup of coffee or like go get
lunch
use this Ross that way but he's not
there so now it's like oh I'm gonna grab
coffee with like you know a girl that's
it's kind of it's kind of a nice change
it yeah so dating but not dating anyone
in particular yeah no one no one has has
captured you know your heart captured my
heart like Ross yeah what are you what
are you guys looking for in a girl yeah
just sort we're pretty um complex yeah
to be I don't think I'm gonna find it in
yeah if I'm looking for something
serious I don't think it's gonna be in
Hollywood and if it is that person is
pretty dope able to hold they got a
strong strong carry yeah but like you
said it's very much
just our lifestyle right now
like we we can't really put someone
above our work sure and that I think a
lot of people can't deal with that were
you guys roommates prior to you moving
to Canada to shoot we've we've been
roommates our life we have it's actually
just the two of you well we lived with
like the rest of the band at one point
and then we live we live with our little
brother now yeah well we've all we've
always been in the same house me and
rocky yeah okay
Bethany says rocky loving your style
today which part yeah my ideal part
Bethany I like the pants yeah and the
shoes these are from someone gave me
these when we did a photo shoot I got
lucky enough to keep the pants on free
stuff anything free that's the biggest
part I'm on a buddy anything in
Hollywood is that for you guys to over
the park it's pretty stuff I mean yeah I
like free stuff doesn't like free stuff
yeah we're gonna take two more fan
questions and we're gonna wrap up here
Bree says rocky will you produce songs
for other bands too
yeah honestly that'll probably happen a
lot more now that he's kind of not there
because usually we're always doing doing
a couple more sessions with just other
friends and I'm constantly everyday I'm
constantly in the studio trying to make
you know something yeah whether it's for
us or just something great yeah yeah
that's the goal is to work with other
artists for sure we've had a lot of cool
instances that we'll have like artist
friends come over and we'll play them a
lot of songs and they they really like
the stuff that we're making which is
really really it's really rewarding
because like we we like a lot of the
stuff that our friends make mm-hmm and
when they come back to us with high
praise it's like it's really nice mm-hmm
I think I think that all always just
kind of like spread and lead to
collaboration yeah sure
you guys are obviously so close so I'm
curious did you have his say and if he
was gonna take the role on Sabrina did
you go to him for advice I did I thought
I honestly I was like yo Rocky like I
did actually want him to like kind of
help me decide because it does affect
him yeah almost as much as it affects me
mm-hmm cuz this is a master
you know I'm gonna be in Canada now for
the rest of the year sure and it's two
seasons right yeah yeah it was
I remember Ross like was you were coming
to me like right before the second table
rain or something
you had a bottle of like black hairspray
and you're like Brodie like sure do it
you were like you're like that just like
died like because they wanted you to dye
your hair for the table for the test
yeah they didn't want me to seem like
that it won't look too much like unit
yeah so he had some nice like CVS just
yeah you're cheap like black Halloween
hairspray yeah
stop but you really did it yourself the
first time the first time then I went to
him and they were like we're gonna hire
someone to come fair enough it's hard to
dye your own hair yeah yeah okay last
question is Danny who says dream
collaboration there's a bunch right now
a child can be no deaf Paul that'd be
great
Pharrell I was a fan of Pharrell need to
get you guys on the festival circuit
yeah can you help with that yeah I want
to copy with Camila Cabello I'm spitting
it out in the world because I feel like
we have this amazing song that she would
sound dope on she follows me on Twitter
really can you hit her up for right into
the DM I guess I'm just gonna keep
saying that in interviews and maybe
it'll get around enough for her to be
like oh yeah there's gonna be a full
montage that she's gonna stumble upon of
you just going hey Camila
yo collaborate video and I guarantee you
she will see it tonight the former
Harmonizers love her I love her
we're gonna get this going rocky loves
rock she her voice is insane right yeah
she's killing it you guys have never met
her though no we met her this happen I'm
not very good we're not I'm like yeah
okay really yeah
okay well we're gonna make this happen I
feel good about it yeah thank you guys
so much for being here let them know
where they can listen to the new song
just search preacher man on anywhere and
then should come on LimeWire has it it's
really good it's gonna make you want to
dance orange yeah
no but seriously yeah music video is out
right now came out a few days ago I
really like it probably my favorite
music video that we've ever been a part
of yeah preacher man it's been out now
for a week some spotify out the music
youtube wherever you want to check it
out if you can't find it there just
follow us on social media yeah if it's
really that challenging but I'm sure
you'll be able to find it and it's all
the driver air right now yes all the
jack awesome thank you guys so much for
watching thank you guys for being here
make sure you subscribe like this page
follow all things et and we'll see you
next time
[Music]